i think that life begins at  fertilization i think our laws should be  clear that little human beings  are made in the image of god they have  value from the moment that they come  into existence we want you to know  christ  that peace with him so please man turn  away  don't go into  [Music]  coming down here though you're trying to  influence  women who may very well have thought  very hard about what they're doing  do you understand that some people might  view that as  misogynistic and anti-democratic  thinking very hard and thinking properly  are two different things right  what we want to do is  have the debate  the cultural tension is there let's  discuss it but you don't believe in the  right to choose i support the right to  choose i don't support the right to kill  innocent babies in the womb  to terminate a pregnancy yeah if you're  afraid  to pressure you to do this there's a  number on the back